welcome to my little channel this is the
place where dreams are broken today
we're on the quest for the scariest
games on the market life studious first
game dungeon nightmares dice we play the
first one [ __ ] terrifying
god damn it let explore the joyful
moments of this one yeah where am I
I say oh it works 9 out of 10 times Oh
Jeff bloody feet does it uh [ __ ] cute
get heads back that off hey yay elevator
I love elevators hey hey hey oh god oh
god it's going down isn't it
alrighty then yeah big deal no big deal
find the artifact and exit now ha ha ha
I don't need an artifact I need to get
the [ __ ] away from here I don't care
about no artifacts [ __ ] that I want to
live so scared so scared so this gets
shut up game don't tell me what to do
I live my own life by my own rules I am
not scared one [ __ ] bed I never I
never been scared ever oh god what the
[ __ ] oh god the skeletons yeah I
remember you bony bony say you pony pony
hey boney how you doing buddy hello shut
up shut up shut the [ __ ] up
alright what the [ __ ] was that what
happened oh my god do I have to go down
again oh my god chairs don't [ __ ]
alright chairs don't [ __ ] how you don't
know how many times I've said it they
never listen they never [ __ ] listen
I'm just gonna run like an idiot what
was that
you bony [ __ ] hmm
there you go what what what [ __ ] the
hell are you doing in my shed brah all
right well I'm just gonna go then
this has been [ __ ] fabulous I love I
love life I love life and I love living
I will never die because I am booty pie
oh boo that rhyme better than I thought
I should be a rapper hey yo my name is
boots I like to alright damn it I got
nothing
all right you bony [ __ ] I know what you
want you want my ass you're not gettin
my ass my ass may be Pony and I'm quite
offended bony all right we're doing
great breasts don't be scared it's just
a video game that [ __ ] vapor oh my
god Jesus [ __ ] ass ABS Jesus ABS hey
boney what the [ __ ] are you doing no bad
bad pony bad boner bad [ __ ] when life
gives you lemon you put them on your
nipples and you make lemon juice that's
what my mom said so I don't know how to
apply it I don't know how to apply that
to this situation but I'm sure we're
gonna figure it out somehow
hey hey I saw you I don't know what that
means pretty but I saw it oh boy when is
this game gonna start getting scary cuz
I am not scared at all hey stones how
are you oh god oh god oh god oh god oh
god oh god okay
it's getting uh what was that well is
that what was that
all right my mom told me if you're ever
scared pills just sing the song of your
people NASCAR you're fina me and flee
yeah serene so they in some so let's go
you're fina me and flee gasoline so in
some Siouxland ha Oh Oh Skippy go Cindy
Circo
shut up we call we call all right be
cool we cool we cool we cool we cool
we're so [ __ ] cool I never been this
cool I never been this cool not even
it's cool
oh that ramp dad told me I could be a
rapper are my jokes funny yet this will
not protect me not but it's just go yes
it is
my god is this the artifact is that the
[ __ ] artifact I've I find out that
the fine you're not gonna scare me I
don't get scared easily I am a man men
don't get scared ever unless unless all
this my penis went underneath there I'd
probably be pretty scared
Hey exit hello we did it we did it we
did it we did it
dance with me you're not doing it right
God Jesus Christ god damn Barry it goes
down no no no no no no no no no no no I
won't ever too good too good to go up up
please
I was just all a dream gonna take a
little break there I sweat like a little
pig when I play these games you didn't
need to know that
oh [ __ ] me you know it next game
gentlemen gentlemen gentlemen gentlemen
gentlemen gentlemen hello hi why do I
have a spinning Christmas tree only a
true gentleman can play this apparently
you have three hands now
xD ok so here's a tree with a disco ball
on it we can't kill it I guess you can't
kill it because it's not live to begin
with alright next game trying to kill me
alright next game piano piano it's it's
blood it's it's it looks so real oh my I
don't know anything but the blood this
is almost scarier than Minecraft don't
look ah
alright so this game is called slender
flowers for girlfriend this could be the
best game ever
I think problem yes it is it is it is
probably yet nope hmm yeah yeah no it is
it's the best all right there's no sound
oh okay you are I I'm gonna [ __ ] your
girlfriend slender man yeah and there's
nothing you can do to stop me
some people say that I play [ __ ] games
and I see what are you talking about
this is truly the pinnacle of gaming in
general the soundtrack 10 out of 10
episode let me warning don't play this
game all right
[Music]
well this evening will be at amore miam
by Jesus Christ [ __ ] hell my god oh
my god oh my god oh my god
hopefully we won't die from heart attack
because I know there's gonna be jumps
case I'm warning you Bryce I'm [ __ ]
warning you hey I miss you man hey are
you ready for our date you look gorgeous
tonight tomorrow alright let's go to
Burger King I want you to get a fat ass
I would guess that you more is like this
fine girl but never never I got there
OTP if you know what I mean alright I'm
gonna keep playing but if you guys pull
the [ __ ] like that again I'm gonna [ __ ]
your [ __ ] up alright I find it really
scary when doors just walk to go through
my face that is kind of terrifying
you know I don't yeah I'm all right say
no say don't do my side or me I'm mommy
yeah hey chin chin - morning Jim hey no
damn dad is looking at ass looks like
look like my grandma's eyes if you know
what am i hey Jeff thinks so bad oh my
god you'll come back yeah I'll come back
after that [ __ ] [ __ ] try to make
out with me
Richard so realize I am a lawful ho to
Tamura me amore Oh God oh no he's
jealous oh god he's jealous - Maurice
jealous this is not good grace
we're fine we're fine I wasn't scared
that was just the scream of justice his
face is so ugly it wasn't fair the [ __ ]
is happening oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] Jesus
Christ my ears just [ __ ] get molested
demoted me amore amore me amore amore
amore amore laughter ten out of ten the
games that I played today I hope you
didn't get too scared that was the quest
for the scariest game I hope you enjoyed
feel free to vote in the description of
the video I'll leave it at voting thing
leave a like if you enjoyed watching it
supports the brows and the hose if you
know what I mean stay awesome bros love
you this is how Satan was born I don't
know why Taylor Swift keeps popping up
in my head there's something that needs
to be done oh my god I've created Satan
how did this happen